drei anläufe hat er gebraucht bis der
parteivorsitzende wurde jetzt ist
friedrich merz erster mann auf der
oppositionsbank und nachlassverwalter
der ära merkel was macht er aus der
mitverantwortung die die cdu unter
anderem für die probleme in der
aktuellen energie krise trägt und wie
steht es um die erneuerung seiner partei
das frage ich heute den cdu
parteivorsitzenden hier in winterberg
herzlich willkommen zum zdf
sommerinterview
[Musik]
die
sie im sauerland herzlich willkommen
herzlich willkommen
bei ihnen in ihrer heimat und in ihrem
wahlkreis hochsauerlandkreis genauer
gesagt in winterberg das muss aber auch
dazu sagen viel los hier wie man sieht
sie haben einen unglaublich großen
wahlkreis habe ich festgestellt als wir
hier hingefahren
der größten in deutschland ja ganz schön
viel strecke die sie zurücklegen müssen
wenn sie sich da um ihre wählerinnen und
wähler kümmern aber sie haben jetzt in
den letzten zwei wochen vor allem
schlagzeilen gemacht mit einer anderen
strecke als sie mit ihrem privatflugzeug
zur hochzeit von christian gentner
geflogen sind bereuen sie eigentlich
dass sie da diese bilder produziert
haben ich habe die bilder nicht
produziert sie sind gemacht worden und
ich bereue nicht dass ich geflogen bin
und dann auf den punkt zu bringen ich
verbrauche mit diesem kleinen flugzeug
weniger sprit als jeder dienstwagen
eines mitglieds der bundesregierung und
deswegen fliege ich das bild wirkt aber
natürlich auch versichern sie haben
gesehen dass es viel kritik ausgelöst
hat und dass die leute da nicht ganz so
genau nachrechnen passt das wirklich
jetzt um diese zeit oder lassen sie
demnächst mal das flugzeug nutzte das
vor allen dingen für berufliche zwecke
stehe dazu und
ist es auch wenn sie so wollen ein alter
traum von mir immer schon gewesen aber
ich weiß dass ich damit behutsam umgehen
müssen dass durch die zeiten sind wie
sie sind und genau darüber wollen wir
gleich sprechen das tun wir aber oben
bei uns am set
[Musik]
herr merz das war jetzt die wochen in
der alle ganz gebannt auf nord stream 1
gestartet habe und auf die frage kommt
da wieder gas jetzt kommt tatsächlich
wieder ein bisschen gas und sie sind
drumherum als oppositionsführer ziemlich
regel gewesen haben die bundesregierung
gut unter druck gesetzt auch was die
energieversorgungssicherheit angeht aber
ich stelle mir die frage haben sie
eigentlich mal nachgerechnet wie viel
gas wie in den speichern hätten wenn die
bundesregierung im märz auf sie gehört
hätte als sie gesagt haben lassen sie
ins nord stream 1 sofort dicht machen um
die sanktionen zu verschärfen pro partie
ich habe ihm früher als der krieg begann
natürlich auch darüber nachgedacht
welche sanktionen sind noch möglich und
habe dazu auch noch 21 genannt
allerdings immer unter dem vorbehalt
dass aus anderen leitungen dies ja auch
noch gibt genug gas nach deutschland
kommt um die leitung zu finden das war
der kontext in dem nord stream 1 genannt
habe in keinem anderen aber sie sind
davon ausgegangen dass man das sofort zu
machen kann und sie haben gesagt wenn
ich das einmal zitieren darf unser
vorschlag auch an die bundesregierung
keinen weiteren bezug von gas aus nord
stream 1 ja haben sie die einschränkung
damals nicht gemacht um die
einschränkung stand in dem kontext weil
ich darauf hingewiesen habe dass es auch
andere leitungen gibt die etwa in
südeuropa verlaufen es war nie
bestritten worden auch von mir nicht
dass wir gas
allerdings haben sie obwohl sie sich
sehr klar für sanktionen ausgesprochen
haben in ihrer partei und ihren ihrer
partei familie momentan nicht mehr ganz
so großen rückhalt markus söder hat sich
jetzt gerade noch einmal geäußert und
hat gesagt auch dass ein zitat die
strategie russlands mit sanktionen
schnell in die knie zu zwingen die ist
nicht aufgegangen wenn man sie hört und
wenn man herrn söder hört da muss man
doch sagen da sind sich zwei unions chef
in einer wesentlichen frage gar nicht
einig was machen sie damit bobadilla
konstruieren sie jetzt ein widerspruch
den ist in dieser form gar nicht gibt
wir sind uns in der union unter auch
zwischen cdu und csu markus söder und
ich völlig einig dass wir diese
sanktionen brauchen dass wir sie auch
fortsetzen müssen niemand von uns ist
davon ausgegangen dass diese sanktionen
schnell wirken und dass wir putin mit
sanktionen innerhalb von wenigen tagen
oder wochen
wie sie gesagt haben in die knie zwingen
sie haben aber auch gehört dass der
syrer gesagt hat im ernstfall sollten
wir noch mal drüber reden nord stream
zwei aufzumachen das klingt ja nicht
nach einer harten linie bei sagen so
etwas ist nicht meine meinung ist auch
nicht die meinung der bundestagsfraktion
ist nicht die meinung der cdu und wir
haben auch mit michael kretschmer einen
ministerpräsidenten in unseren reihen
der das aus der sächsischen perspektive
anders sieht aber auch das ist nicht die
meinung der union sie haben gewusst dass
ich danach jetzt fragen wer
welche cage mel ist er stellvertreter
ist eine sehr wichtige stimme in ihrer
partei der sagt sogar er möchte gerne öl
und gas aus russland beziehen für noch
mindestens weitere fünf jahre steht er
damit dann jetzt völlig allein aus ihrer
sicht es ist seine meinung wir gehen
davon aus dass die bundesregierung mit
dem plan den sie hat nämlich kohle bald
will bis zum ende des jahres vollständig
zu ersetzen aus anderen quellen
erfolgreich sein wird hier steht für die
ostdeutschen länder insbesondere in
frage das werk in schwedt die raffinerie
dort die praktisch den ganzen osten
deutschlands mit
benzin versorgt übrigens auch die
flughäfen und dass wir daran ein
nationales interesse haben dass diese
versorgung aufrecht erhalten bleibt ist
völlig klar wir diskutieren über den weg
aber nicht über das ziel dass damit
unterstützen sie also auch die forderung
die fünf wirtschaftspolitische sprecher
der cdu in den ost bundesländern gemacht
haben dass also steht auf jeden fall
auch weiter rohstoffe aus russland
beziehen soll schwedt braucht rohstoffe
und es geht jetzt um die frage woher
kommen die und so bald ist klar ist dass
wir kein öl mehr aus russland beziehen
muss diese raffinerie mit anderen öl
versorgt werden die quellen gibt es um
die müssen erschlossen werden und da
sind wir uns im ziel völlig einig
schwedt darf nicht stillgelegt werden
das ist da was machen sie wenn es keine
alternativen gibt dann denken wir
darüber nach welche alternativen wir
dann noch erwähnen können haben sie das
ihren ort kollegen auch noch mal auch
schon mal gesagt dass es dann trotzdem
kein öl aus russland geht wir sprechen
darüber ich habe auch mit den bundestags
kollegen
vor gar nicht langer zeit zusammen
gesessen und haben genau dieses thema
miteinander diskutiert und wir sind uns
einig wir brauchen hier einen blick auch
auf die ostdeutschen bundesländer unter
strom aus sie haben sich vor ein paar
tagen noch bei ihrem besuch bei der
csu-fraktion noch mal sehr deutlich
geäußert und haben gesagt es geht in
diesem ukraine krieg und in dem konflikt
auch darum dass wir demokratie und
freiheit und frieden auch bei uns
verteidigen auch da liegen sie nicht
ganz auf einer linie mit herrn
kretschmann der fordert nämlich ein
sofortiges einfrieren des ukraine
konfliktes auch mit blick auf die
wirtschaftliche lage im osten
und er möchte dieser position in der cdu
gerne mehr gehör verschaffen wie viel
raum werden es diese debatte in ihrer
partei geben wir haben in der partei
natürlich diskussionen über dieses thema
aber wir haben auch eine ganz klare
meinung es gibt dazu auch
vorstandsbeschlüsse und ich will es mal
mit den worten einer ministerpräsident
den aus den baltischen staaten sagen mit
frau callas aus
mitte aus island die dortige
ministerpräsidentin ist ja vor einiger
zeit mal in einem lokal am deutschen
interview gesagt energiemarkt teuer sein
aber freiheit ist unbezahlbar und in
dieser haltung sind wir uns eigentlich
diese einigkeit wie spielt man nicht
wenn man herrn kretschmer zuhört er hat
ja auch sehr deutliche worte dort
gefunden und er ist eben offensichtlich
nicht bereit jedes opfer zu bringen
haben sie da eine ost west buch in der
cdu nein sie zitieren jetzt sehr häufig
michael kretschmer aber er ist nicht der
einzige ministerpräsident im osten ist
auch andere stimmen trotzdem ist es so
vor energie er ist nicht der einzige und
in alle anderen ministerpräsidentin
präsidenten in ostdeutschland sind
anderer meinung und die cdu auch sie
haben im bundestag in einer rede zu
beginn des krieges diejenigen die auf
putin zu gehen und ihm in die hände
spielen auch aus eigeninteresse als
nützliche idioten bezeichnet diese
bezeichnung die verwenden sie nicht mit
blick auf ihre eigenen
parteimitglieder die wir gerade
angesprochen haben die ja auch mit ihren
forderungen herrn putin in die hand
warum nicht das sind völlig andere
sachverhalte ich habe über politiker
gesprochen insbesondere aus der spd die
mit russland geschäfte machen die sich
in eine persönliche abhängigkeit begeben
haben die sich eine politische
abhängigkeit begeben haben wie zum
beispiel der schulter der immer noch in
der spd ist obwohl der parteivorsitzende
ihn dort nicht mehr haben will ich habe
immer vor schwesig gesprochen die dort
eine windige konstruktion mit einer
stiftung in mecklenburg vorpommern
aufgestellt hat um an allen sanktionen
vorbei und an nordstream zwei
festgehalten hat das sind diejenigen die
ich gemalt habe nicht andere die sind
allerdings nicht alleine gewesen wir
haben in den letzten 16 jahren zum teil
und herr schröder natürlich nicht aber
andere die sie genannt haben zum teil
auch in der ära angela merkel mit
gearbeitet da ist ja einiges
zusammengekommen was sich jetzt dort
aufgebaut hat und womit wir zu tun haben
meine kollegin patricia wiedemeier hat
einmal geschaut in welcher situation sie
die führenden der cdu übernommen haben
und ende dieser ära merkel
16 jahre lang stellte die cdu die
kanzlerin die folge deutschland ist mehr
als andere länder abhängig vom
russischen gas die digitalisierung kommt
nicht voran die infrastruktur steht kurz
vor dem zusammenbruch
es war ein wirtschaftsminister der cdu
mitverantwortlich für lehre gasspeicher
und den gebremsten ausbau der
erneuerbaren energie es waren fünf
verteidigungs minister und ministerinnen
der union die bundeswehr ist kaputt
gespart nicht mal mehr in der lage das
eigene land zu verteidigen und vier
verkehrsminister alle von der
schwesterpartei csu die folge chaos bei
der bahn dauerstaus auf deutschlands
autobahnen doch der cdu vorsitzende will
keine verantwortung übernehmen hören sie
auf über 16 jahre zu reden dieser befund
heute ist ihre herausforderungen und
wenn es so bleibt meine damen und herren
dann ist es allein ihre verantwortung 16
jahre cdu im kanzleramt keine wirklich
gute bilanz herr merz als
oppositionsführer teilen sie naturgemäß
hart gegen die bundesregierung aus das
ist schon klar aber sie müssen noch
aufzugeben in den vergangenen 16 jahren
hat ihre partei und hat die union
eigentlich den grundstein für fast jede
groß krise gelegt die wir jetzt sehen wo
arbeiten sie denn die fehler auf die da
passiert sind davor war natürlich den
letzten 16 jahren waren wir in der
regierung aber wir waren nie alleine von
diesen 16 jahren waren zwölf jahre die
sozialdemokraten dabei in den letzten
vier jahren bei olaf scholz der
finanzminister und wie wir beide wissen
hat der finanzminister das kassenbuch
der bundesrepublik deutschland unter
machen aber jetzt spielen sie die
richtlinienkompetenz ganz schön runter
die sie da hatte ich bekenne mich zu der
verantwortung die die cdu in der zeit
hatte ohne jede frage und wir
diskutieren natürlich darüber wir wissen
dass wir fehler gemacht haben wobei wenn
ich sage wir ich war von den zwölf nur
16 selbst aber irgendwo viel von den 16
uhr vier selbst dabei zwölf nicht aber
darüber müssen wir natürlich reden aber
wir übernehmen diese verantwortung auch
aber noch mal wir haben sie nicht
alleine getragen und wenn sie über die
bundeswehr sprechen dann kann ich nur
sagen der bundesfinanzminister olaf
scholz hatte eine finanzplanung für die
bundeswehr die ging noch weiter runter
als wir sie gesehen haben in unserer
gemeinsamen regierungszeit von ja dann
von der cdu korrigiert wo vorher auch
schon unter csu sehr heftig mit dem
sparen angefangen worden ist aber sie
macht man sich sagen auch nicht alleine
cdu abgeordnete sondern es war auch ein
spd-wirtschaftsminister dabei als wenn
wir über verantwortung sprechen dann
sprechen wir gemacht sie nicht alleine
tragen das ist klar geworden aber sie
haben es auch gerade schon erwähnt sie
selber sind nicht direkt dabei gewesen
damit sind wir auch schon bei der
aufgabe die sie eigentlich auch noch vor
der brust haben als cdu vorsitzender sie
haben nämlich die mammut aufgabe vor
sich ihre partei neu aufzustellen und in
gewisser weise auch wieder
zusammenzuführen intern aber auch mit
der csu
man hat da von ihnen
sehr viel mehr konservatives profil
erwartet und eine abkehr von der ära
merkel wenn man sich jetzt mal anschaut
was in ihrer in der ersten zeit ihrer
amtszeit so passiert ist hat man den
eindruck da passiert gerade eher das
gegenteil diejenigen die wahlen gewinnen
sind eher auf dem merkel mitte kurs
hendrik wüst und daniel günther das
erste große die erste große entscheidung
die sie vorbereiten ist die einführung
der frauenquote gegen die sie persönlich
mal gewesen sind was ist denn aus dem
konservativen reformer märz geworden
dieser konservative friedrich merz ist
immer war seiner meinung geblieben zum
beispiel beim thema frauenquote
nein ich habe immer gesagt dass die
zweitbeste lösung ich habe nie
bestritten dass wir ein problem haben
und dieses problem müssen wir lösen ist
es nun allerdings auch nicht das größte
problem dieses land ist es ist ein
problem meiner partei und wir sind dabei
dieses problem auch zu lösen ich habe
einen vorschlag gemacht und dann werden
wir darüber im september auf dem
bundesparteitag in hannover diskutieren
und eine entscheidung treffen aber wir
wissen auch dass dieses land andere
themen hat und dass die menschen von
anderen themen bewegt werden als von der
frauenquote der cd die sie aber auch
nicht liegen lassen können deswegen
haben sie sich also entschieden wie sie
sich entschieden haben und momentan
verlagern sie damit vor allem den
parteinachwuchs der mal quasi ihr
größter fan war die junge union bereitet
einen gegenantrag vor und die wird das
nicht kampflos hinnehmen wollen die
haben gesagt also wir waren mal sehr
begeistert von friedrich merz aber das
war sein da jetzt tut das ist ein
krasser fehler da verlieren sie ihre
fernseher ja ich will es noch mal
richtig einordnen frau bahn ag also wir
haben in der tat die systeme schon seit
jahren auf der tagesordnung ich habe
einen vorschlag gemacht wie wir
vielleicht einen kompromiss finden
können wenn es jetzt anträge gibt dann
schauen wir uns die gemeinsam an wir
werden in der antragskommission
versuchen auch noch einmal einen
vernünftigen weg aufzuzeigen wie man das
lösen kann aber ich will das auch an die
adresse der jungen union sagen dieses
land hat andere probleme die junge
generation steht vor anderen
herausforderungen als vor der frage ob
die cdu die frauenquote einführt ich
möchte dass wir genug frauen in der
partei haben mehr als heute ich möchte
dass junge frauen für die partei und in
der partei arbeiten aber das geht um
sachfragen und gar nicht so sehr um
personalfragen wenn sie sagen das land
hat andere probleme dann kann man noch
mal zur csu schauen weil die frage wie
sie diese probleme lösen dann auch nicht
immer ganz unumstritten ist es gab da
schon wieder scharfe töne von markus
söder in sachen tempolimit bei der frage
sollte man dann möglicherweise weil
insgesamt paket ein tempolimit mit
einbringen bei der frage was kann noch
dazu beitragen energie zu sparen und
markus söder hat damit anscheinend nicht
darüber anscheinend nicht mit ihnen
gesprochen sondern mit der presse und
hat gesagt das ist kuhhandel den machen
wenn ich mit wer setzt sich dann als
auch da gibt es eine ganz klare
gemeinsame haltung das tempolimit ist
ein symbolthema damit würden wir auch
weder ökologisch noch verkehrstechnisch
die probleme lösen es gibt den einen
oder anderen in unserer partei der der
meinung müssten sollten das einführen
ich bin nicht der meinung trotzdem ist
es auch dieses thema ordnen was bitte
richtig ein die probleme dieses landes
sind nicht mit dem tempo auf autobahnen
vielleicht drei prozent der strecken auf
denen es in deutschland noch kein
tempolimit gibt sie verlangen an anderer
stelle aber auch dass man an allen
schräubchen dreht ihr ein bisschen
helfen können also werden sie das
tempolimit mit als vorhanden sein wenn
die bundesregierung mit uns über
verschiedene themen reden will vor allen
dingen anders reden will als dies in der
vergangenheit getan hat bis jetzt liegt
die bundesregierung unsere vorschläge
jahr regelmäßig alle ab dann kommen sie
plötzlich zwei wochen später doch wieder
gibt ein beispiel wir haben über das
viel wichtiger als tempolimit wir haben
über das thema biomasse und verstromung
gesprochen der bundesregierung den
vorschlag gemacht den deckel runter die
biomasse uneingeschränkt für strom
abgelehnt im bundes ist jetzt auch ein
bis zwei wochen später kündigt der
bundeskanzler dass anders als jetzt noch
machen will wir hatten andere themen wo
es in die gleiche richtung ging es sind
alles ab ich sage ihnen auch voraus wir
werden am ende des jahres sehen dass die
laufzeit der kernkraftwerke verlängert
wird haben es vorgeschlagen die
bundesregierung lehnt sie ab wenn die
bundesregierung mit uns reden will
ernsthaft reden was sie zurzeit nicht
tot wieder auf der parlamentarischen
ebene noch auf der regierungsebene
hanseatische bereich gesucht wir bieten
das immer an aber wir laufen der
bundesregierung nicht hinterher wir
kriegen zehn minuten vor sitzungsbeginn
300 seiten änderungsanträge zu den in
die gesetzen des
bundeswirtschaftsministers das ist keine
art des umgangs mit dem parlament wenn
sie mit uns vernünftig reden wollen
sollen sie es tun wir sind jederzeit
bereit die stirn stehen immer offen aber
bitte dann nicht indem wir etwas
vorgelegt bekommen nach dem motto vogel
friss oder stirb das ist keine art des
umgangs und da werden wir auch ganz hart
bleiben mit unserem projekt wir noch
einmal bei ihrer aufgabe bleiben könnten
als cdu-vorsitzender und
co-vorsitzender sozusagen innerhalb der
union mit markus söder wenn sie von
markus söder da immer wieder solche
kleinen sticheleien von der seitenlinie
mitbekommen machen sie sich da sorgen
dass sie das bis zum bayern weil
eigentlich aushalten müssen und da
einfach nur zuschauen nein überhaupt
nicht und das ist auch nicht der
befunden markus söder und ich arbeite
wirklich sehr sehr gut zusammen wir
haben jeden montagmorgen eine
video-konferenz mit dem engsten
führungskreis beider parteien jeden
montagmorgen um 8 uhr wir stimmen uns
jede woche miteinander ab wir
telefonieren viel miteinander wir sehen
uns wo immer möglich es gibt zwischen
markus söder und mir weder persönlich
irgendeine störung noch politisch
irgendeine differenz wir haben hin und
wieder unterschiedliche auffassungen zu
einzelnen sagten aber das ist ganz
normal wir sind nicht eine in uniform
gepackte partei sondern wir sind eine
diskussionsfreudige partei auch die
beiden vorsitzenden minuten wir
unterschiedliche auffassungen aber das
ist nicht substanziell ist sondern das
ist eine enge sehr partnerschaftliche
vertrauensvolle zusammenarbeit sie haben
ersten teil des gespräches schon einmal
gesagt dass sie nicht alleine die
verantwortung übernehmen werden als cdu
für die bilanz der 16 jahre
unionsgeführte regierung sie haben auch
im vergangenen jahr die bilanz von
angela merkel als kanzlerin immer wieder
sehr stark gelobt wenn sie sich jetzt
die aktuelle situation anschauen und die
probleme mit denen wir konfrontiert sind
auch als folge dieser 16 jahre würden
sie das noch mal so formulieren naja ich
habe ja in der presse viel kritik dafür
bekommen auch von ihnen dass ich die
bundeskanzlerin
ein jahr vorher ziemlich hart kritisiert
habe also wie es auch machen war es
offensichtlich nur halb richtig und halb
falsch aber bleiben sich dem lob das ist
eingeleitet dabei das waren die
uneingeschränkt sondern ich habe immer
gesagt angela merkel hat ihre großen
verdienste um dieses land wir alle haben
bestimmte situationen falsch
eingeschätzt wir stehen heute vor großen
herausforderungen und mein blick richtet
sich nach vorn der rest ist eine frage
die die historiker beantworten müssen da
gibt es viel zu tun wenn sie nach vorne
blicken ich danke ihnen erst mal an
dieser stelle an gegen die sie
ansprechen
das war unser zdf sommerinterview mit
dem cdu vorsitzenden in der kommenden
woche geht es weiter mit theo koll und
der co vorsitzenden der grünen ricarda
lang herzlichen dank an sie fürs
zuschauen und einen schönen abend
[Musik]